one of the oldest most tired and
unsophisticated tropes of the american
right wing is calling anything nuance to
anything
intellectual even simply something
science based
gay or sometimes they'll use the code
word effeminate if they're a little
slicker
like fox news propagandist tucker
carlson and indeed last night tucker
carlson
did a commentary about this entire
pandemic
and it was sort of a rant about how all
these doctor doctors and experts telling
us what to do uh
aren't the people that we should be
following and that there's something
sort of not
masculine in fact about following people
like dr fauci
and tucker devolves into the basis of
base arguments
which is that listening to public health
experts like dr fauci
makes one delicate timid and effeminate
which are just sophisticated
words for the right wing to say oh
that's gay man that's really gay
and of course tucker hides this by
saying this is the view
of some chinese adviser to the
government why tucker cares
what a chinese advisor would say when
typically tucker is denouncing
the chinese communist party i don't know
but here it's convenient
and tucker says look the advisor says
that it's a masculinity crisis it's
effeminate to do this stuff and
it's sort of like when we listen to dr
fauci take a listen to this
well this tells you everything in march
of last year the leadership of the
united states and of china both declared
national emergencies in the u.s tony
fauci warned congress that
reopening american businesses could
cause coronavirus outbreaks the
government may not be able to control
going outside tony fauci said was just
too risky
meanwhile in china where the chronovirus
originated a top
advisor to the chinese government
declared that the country was
experiencing a very different kind of
threat a more profound threat
the problem he said was a national
masculinity crisis chinese boys quote
have been spoiled by housewives and
female teachers
and they were becoming as a result quote
delicate timid and effeminate
in essence they were becoming people who
might listen to someone like tony fauci
left unchecked said the chinese
government advisor
the feminization of chinese boys would
quote inevitably endanger the survival
and development of the chinese nation
did you see how tucker did that he
doesn't use the word gay
and he doesn't say it's his idea but
then he says
it's sort of like listening to dr fauci
the chinese doctor saying we've become
delicate timid and effeminate that's
sort of like when we listen to dr fauci
when dr fauci as a doctor explains how
viruses work and suggests what people
should do
if you listen to that it's sort of gay
that's that's the code language
that is being used here this is just red
meat for the right
it's another version of the real men
don't go to the doctor
type of sort of troglodytic thinking
now maybe natural selection prefers a
feminine timid and delicate i don't know
i guess we'll see who survives this
thing but they're not even
trying to hide their contempt and
resentment
for anybody who listens to actual
experts rather than fox news so-called
experts
now you really have to think about what
the end game is here because it strikes
me as a logical and what i mean by that
is fox news's audience is
disproportionately
older folks who we know are more at risk
of dying from coronavirus
if fox news is audience followed the
advice of fox news hosts for the last
year
many of them would be dying when they
didn't have to die fox news would be
essentially killing off its own audience
and it makes no sense in that context
so the end game can't possibly be that
but it's all
part of the political movement that
pushed the anti-mass protests for
freedom
promoted donald trump's radiologist dr
scott atlas's views on a communicable
disease completely outside of his area
of expertise generally
promoted ignoring science on just about
every aspect of the pandemic
and it's amazing how much things change
and yet
how much things stay the same so much
has changed in society and culture
since when i was in school in the 90s
and it was common to say oh that's gay
and yet tucker carlson a 51 year old man
in 2021
is going right back to that same trope
now one last thought just as an aside
is tucker carlson now the image of
right-wing masculinity
and i asked that in a serious way i
don't care how tucker looks i care about
what tucker says
but is it now is this
the image that republicans now consider
the pinnacle of masculinity
a bow tie-wearing sort of high-pitched
voice country club guy maybe it is i
don't know
and i don't care what tucker looks like
or what he sounds like i care about what
he says
but it's also kind of weird to me that
he's talking about
it's effeminate to listen to doctors
when i don't
recognize tucker as the image of
right-wing masculinity that's sort of
bandied about
at the motorcycle rallies and the
shooting ranges i don't know
now just one more thing tucker in the
opening
also said going outside
is too risky according to dr fauci
i looked and looked and couldn't find
any instances throughout this pandemic
of dr fauci saying stay in your homes i
i just couldn't find it so it seems that
also
even on the premise even on the facts
tucker carlson is not surprisingly
completely wrong again one of our
sponsors
is monk pack it's tough to get excited
about most granola bars they have a lot
of carbs
they don't taste that great they don't
really satisfy your cravings
but monk pack has something totally
different monk pack
keto granola bars are sweet and
delicious
with a soft and chewy texture
only 140 calories one gram of sugar
and only two to three net carbs which
make them work
perfectly for the keto or low carb
lifestyles
they come in excellent flavors like
coconut cocoa chip
honey nut blueberry almond vanilla
that's my new favorite
i love these because you can just grab
them anytime maybe it's a quick
breakfast
an afternoon snack when you're busy
forget the dry
bland granola bars you've had in the
past try out
monk pack keto granola bars if you don't
love them like i do
they'll give you all of your money back
you'll get twenty percent off when you
go to monkpack.com and use the coupon
code
pacman the link is underneath this video